it's a gift sometimes you fall
romantically in love with someone and
and there'll be the romantic adventures
that go along with that but
it's only a gift for a short time after
that it has to be something that you
strive to attain you know and even in
the
initial phases of a relationship you
strive if you put your best foot
forward if you're trying to impress the
person you could say well that's being
false but well maybe it's allowing
who you are to shine through briefly you
know
if you're not a complete psychopath and
manipulative
you put some effort into it and then you
think well i fall in love with this
person that should just continue it's
like that isn't how it works
so chapter uh so that's actually chapter
eight and chapter nine
uh chapter nine i thought this one was
really interesting because this i think
maybe
came up more consistently in the q a
than than anything
else uh if old memories still upset you
write write them down carefully and
completely there was a lot of questions
related to this sort of thing where
people would say
okay jordan i've i've followed the 12
rules and i've i'm
i'm not an alcoholic anymore i'm off
drugs i've healed this relationship i
got a better job
some version of all of that but what
they would often say and i think
i'd talk to you about this sometimes
with myself i still felt guilt about
things from the past
even though my life had moved past them
and you would always say well you should
do the self-authoring
uh program which i did do but that in
essence is what you're saying here
i think as well well if something still
if something still has emotional
resonance
so it's plaguing you it's it's
possessing you
you can't let go of it it's your baggage
you don't want to think about it now
this is
this is look if you're in the midst of a
catastrophe
dwelling on the catastrophe is not
necessarily a good idea
i'm talking about we could use as a rule
of thumb
things that happened more than two years
ago that would be safe
because otherwise maybe they're still
going on and you're immersed in them and
you can't make sense of them
and dwelling on them just makes the
catastrophe worse old memories things
you know you should be over
if they're still emotionally resonant
especially if it's
that the emotion is negative anger fear
hatred resentment something like that
then
there's information locked up in that
that you haven't
unpacked and what that means see because
you build yourself out of the
information that you encounter in the
world
what that means is that part of you is
still stuck
it's as if part of you is still stuck in
that experience
and or it's as if there's territory that
you traversed that you haven't mapped
and so you might fall into the same hole
again
and your emotions are indicating that
they're saying there's a dane there's
danger here there's danger here
there's unprocessed danger here attend
to it well you don't want to
and no wonder you have to dig into it
and then you have to map
it and your map is effective when
you you've rearranged your perceptions
or your behavior so that that event is
unlikely to occur again in the future
that's really the purpose of your memory
is
you remember things so you don't make
the same stupid mistakes again
that's a pragmatic that's the pragmatic
utility of memory
and so you see this to some degree in
psychotherapy
you know this the freudians in
particular emphasized
past trauma and you can emphasize that
far
too much like so that's it's not as if
a therapeutic process should be
necessarily obsessive concern with
your childhood but if if you're still
plagued by memories
you can't let them go they're not mapped
it's an indication that you have not
fully mined the the
the
you have not fully benefited from what
you've been offered
there's wisdom laying there and so you
can do that by writing
this happened this is what i remember
this is how it makes me feel well why
did it happen
what could have i done differently
what's the significance now
am i misinterpreting this there's a lot
of clinical stories that i modified
because
for you know concern for my clients
privacy
but i kept the stories intact
you reconfigure your personality by
dealing with what you have not yet dealt
with and then it stops interfering with
your present
so you know what i think it might be
that you view your current the person
you have a current relationship
with through the through eyes that have
been affected by
a multitude of relationship failures
and so you're projecting assumptions
onto this person and
and because you've been hurt
and you have to untangle all of that
before you can get beyond that
and so you catch up with yourself that
way
so that's what that's that's an
injunction to do that
yeah clean up your past and if you don't
it leads to a lot of the other stuff
that that you've been talking about here
uh number 10
uh well it sort of works off the the
relationship part that you just
mentioned
uh plan and work diligently to maintain
the romance
in your relationship you know one of the
things that i consistently saw on the
tour is that you you and tammy really
love each other
and there was a lot of struggles there
obviously with her health at first
but it was just obvious the way you
behaved towards you know after every
single show i'd usually go into the
green room with you
we'd do a little download of you know
what happened
and and then immediately when tammy
would walk in you'd say the same thing
every night
how was it tonight and and you meant it
like you wanted to know
she's the most important person in your
life and you wanted to know what she
thought of what you just did
and that was important
yeah and we're still together despite i
feel bad for her
unfortunately having to live with me at
current time
it's very difficult and she's certainly
been through her
own hell but has come out
of it intact so
this chapter romance is like beauty it's
a grace
it's a gift and people
and you have to you have to but you have
to work at it like it's a gift sometimes
you fall romantically in love with
someone and
and there'll be the romantic adventures
that go along with that but
it's only a gift for a short time after
that it has to be something that you
strive to attain you know and even
in the initial phases of a relationship
you strive if you put your best foot
forward if you're trying to impress the
person you could say well that's being
false but well maybe it's allowing
who you are to shine through briefly you
know
if you're not a complete psychopath and
manipulative
you put some effort into it and then you
think well i fall in love with this
person that should just continue it's
like that isn't how it works
you have to just like if you want your
room to be beautiful you have to buy
paintings and art and you and and and
furniture that's functional and
beautiful and
you have to work at it you have to
attend to it and romance is the same
thing it's
it's vital but it's delicate it's a form
of play
and play in children if any other
motivational state emerges
in a child's psyche they'll stop playing
hunger thirst tired they're tired
they're hot they're cold
they're lonesome all of that will
disrupt play even though play is vital
and romance is the adult form of play
and the conditions have to be set up for
it and so
when i was doing my clinical work i
would say to my clients well
set at least one evening a week aside
for a romantic
adventure and then figure out what
that's going to look like what would you
like well then you have to ask yourself
well what is it that i would like what
do i need and then
that's often real difficult because you
won't even admit it you want to keep it
in the fog
you know you don't want to have the
fight with your partner you don't want
to have the discussion with your partner
you don't want to light candles you feel
foolish you don't want to put on
some clothes that are semi-attractive
because you're embarrassed about your
body or
whatever it might be this is all
extremely difficult
but but you can get
better and better at it and maybe it can
be more than hell do it once a month to
begin with
and and do it badly allow your partner
to be
crabby and not you know fully
immersed in it till you get good at it
you might have to do it 40 times before
you're even
vaguely good at it like anything else
that's complex
but you might as well you might as well
do it
and then then maybe you can keep the
mystery of your partner alive to some
degree and you won't be
so tempted to find your romantic
adventure elsewhere
you know it's funny this may not be the
exact example you're going for here but
i know and and you got to spend some
time with
with david as well but like if i we've
been together for 10 years if i can make
him laugh still which i
try to do every day and i'm usually
pretty good at it it's like to me that's
like the greatest thing like wow
after 10 years this guy still thinks i'm
funny like he knows all my tricks
and he still thinks i'm funny that's
pretty good right there
absolutely well that's a form of play
too
you know and and we
we tammy and i put a lot of effort into
that and it definitely paid off and
we put our we put ourselves on the line
you know she's quite confident
physically
much more so than than i was probably
much more so than i still am
and that was very helpful to me but
then it's another situation where you
can imagine you could have the perfect
romantic evening well you could maybe
yeah you know like it's not it's not
going to be easy to get to perfect
that's for sure but
you could get to a reasonable
approximation of it
and why not you don't have anything
better to do
than that so that's that chapter
it's very practical the book is like the
first book i thought it's
you know i try to discuss things at the
highest level of abstraction
even a religious level of abstraction
but it's all very practical
if you'd like to see more honest and
insightful conversations with jordan
peterson himself check out our jordan
peterson playlist which includes every
interview i've ever done with him and if
you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
both are right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell